hi YouTube I'm Josette Sheeran the head
of the World Food Program and as you may
know we've reached out to 90 million
people every year who don't have enough
to eat and we try to provide them
life-saving food with the soaring food
prices the bottom billion are really
getting hit hard so we have one request
here at Davos fill this Cup this is a
cup from a school in northern Uganda and
every day we fill this Cup for 20
million children in the world it would
cost three billion a year to say that
every child goes to school has something
to eat for most of these kids this is
all they get to eat every year every day
is one cup of food so we're asking
costume euro a week to fill this is a
practical step maybe we can't end human
hunger this year but can we at least say
that no child on earth goes to school
hungry can we at least say that each
child gets one cup of food by the way
for many of the children who get this
cup of food it's the only food they get
all day so that's our request is
something practical something real let's
end hunger for school children so they
can listen and learn and create a new
future for themselves so that's our
request is fill the red cup please